At a panel I was hosting during Magic on
Vegas a few weeks ago, an audience
member asked a question that really got
me thinking.
>> I've been trying to build a hidden
commander and
I I don't know how to make it work.
Uh it's the Simic Ceremony. It's green,
black. Creature spells cost two less to
cast and whenever creature you control
enters, if you cast it, destroy that
creature, then you get a token.
I don't want to just make it a token
instead.
>> [clears throat]
>> How do I make weird niche hidden
commanders work?
>> Hidden commanders are an interesting
subject, but they definitely aren't all
made equal. I responded to this person's
question, as well as my co-host's
answer, by saying that some of the
classically touted examples of
build-around cards, such as Sunforger,
are deceptively simple to pull off
because the cards they work with don't
eat up that much deck space. Red and
white instance that cost four or less
mana are good and you'll already want
some of them in your deck. Equipments
are also good and you should be able to
find some other options to grab if you
want to run tutors for your Sunforger.
However, for a secret commander that
typically requires more deck space to
support it, as the Simic Ceremony often
does, you'll need to thread the needle a
bit more carefully in deck building.
>> The second question would be are there
analogs? Are there cards that will do
what you want to do with the Simic
Ceremony kind of that aren't it? Because
if if people get to know this deck, they
will start removing this card very very
rapidly. So,
uh I think that'll be the other thing
you want to look at is if you are
dedicating a lot of deck space to this
card, what else can work with this card?
So, I think that's kind of where you
need to be looking.
>> And that felt like pretty good advice to
give generally. Cards don't always get
drawn and sometimes get removed. I
tangled with the Simic Ceremony myself a
bit a year prior for a video building a
deck based around cards chosen by my
patrons. So, I had some familiarity with
that card in particular and its
challenges, but I'm by no means an
expert. That deck was a little on the
goofy side and the card isn't really my
first choice as a build-around in the
first place. So, I figured it could be
somebody else's job to be a scholar on
the Sidsig Ceremony in particular.
However, that plan was upended about a
week later when I was spinning a wheel
to decide what deck I'd build for the
Magic Mirror podcast.
>> My card, pretty much the same thing.
>> Dragon storm, dragon storm, dragon
storm. Oh, no.
>> Oh, please no.
>> Oh, yes.
>> Oh, god, no.
>> Sidsig Ceremony. This card keeps coming
up.
>> The set of wheels I created spun me into
building a $60 budget deck with 50 or
more subtypes in some way centered
around the Sidsig Ceremony, this old
nemesis of mine. At this point, I just
accepted that I needed to create a full
effort build-around for this card in
order to shake whatever curse had caused
it to follow me.
And to be clear, I do mean an
honest-to-god bracket three deck, maybe
a little janky by choice and by nature
of the requirements going into this
deck, but no jankier than that and with
plenty of powerful plays up its sleeve.
In the process of doing precisely this,
I ended up landing on two principles
that should guide anybody building a
deck centered around a card in their 99.
One of these being something I directly
identified at the panel, and the other
one being something I kind of alluded to
more indirectly and have since developed
further.
These principles are: one, find analogs
for your central card, and two, minimize
the footprint of cards that synergize
with your central card. With both
principles stemming from the essential
fact that you simply won't always have
access to your hidden commander card.
So, in this video, I'm going to walk you
through my process of building a Sidsig
Ceremony deck and in doing so,
demonstrate how these two rules produced
a successful hidden commander deck.
To start with, let's discuss the nature
of hidden commanders a bit and why the
Sidsig Ceremony is one of the trickier
ones you can choose. The phrase hidden
commander simply refers to a deck where
one of the cards in the 99 is built
around more heavily than the commander
itself. My Sharuum Astral Slide deck is
an example of this, where Astral Slide
is a key piece of how the deck works and
Sharuum plays more of a secondary role
in adding flexibility and resilience to
the deck. This type of deck usually
involves some number of tutors to find
the core card, although whether or not a
deck tutors for its hidden commander
every game might depend on the nature of
the card a bit. Astral Slide is a
ridiculously powerful late game tool, so
I'll almost always want a copy of the
card at some point even if I survive the
early to mid game without it. For
purposes of adhering to principle one,
having analogs, Astral Slide makes my
job easy because it has a functionally
identical card as well as a similar
enchantment in a different color,
effectively giving me three copies of my
key card. I don't need to get creative
finding cards to do something similar.
They're just handed to me. Other hidden
commanders make principle number two the
easy one, allowing a player to minimize
the footprint of cards that work with
their central card quite easily and not
feel like their deck space is being
gobbled up. As I mentioned earlier,
Sunforger is a great build around
because the cards it works with span a
wide range of different roles, and since
they don't even need to be in hand for
Sunforger to synergize with them, the
challenge of figuring out the right
number of instance to guarantee setup
and payoff lining up is basically
non-existent. So, these are two secret
commanders where one of the two
principles I mentioned earlier is
basically guaranteed, easing a bit of
the challenge of deck building.
However, some hidden commanders don't
make either of these two principles
easy, and this brings us to the Sibsig
Ceremony.
Let's start, as I did when building this
deck, by tackling what this card does.
The first line of text is 100% upside.
It makes our creature spells cost two
less. That's a pretty great effect for
three mana. Urza's Incubator and
Semblance Anvil come the closest to this
rate among artifact-based producers, but
each of these has a substantial downside
or limitation. So does the Sibsig
Ceremony, though. The second line of
text destroys creatures when they enter
if they were cast and creates a 2/2
Zombie. This does place a serious
limitation on what's going to make sense
to go with this card, though it's
definitely not an insurmountable
limitation. When I was searching for a
commander for this card, I knew I wanted
it to be something on the more generic
side to work out with the other
restrictions I'd been given. And I also
knew I wanted it to do something that
combines relatively easy with the Simic
Ceremony to produce positive outcomes.
In other words, I wanted something low
footprint. A commander that kind of just
works with the Simic Ceremony without me
needing to put in a lot of extra effort
or bring in additional cards. This is
how I landed on Athreos, Shroud-Veiled.
The card is six mana, it's
indestructible even when I have it fully
online via devotion, and it has an
ability that works well alongside ETBs
and on death effects among creatures I
play.
Even without anything else on my side of
the board, the card is just pretty solid
if I get it into play on turn four off a
turn three ceremony and start throwing
coins on opposing creatures. Effectively
making Simic Ceremony a worn power stone
for this precise function.
To go along with this, I grabbed a
handful of other indestructible and
pseudo indestructible creatures. Erebos,
Bleak-Hearted as another god that works
well with my zombie tokens, Yahenni as a
sac outlet, Breathkeeper Seraph as a
unique soulbond creature that can save
itself and others, and all four in-color
Myojins. These are eight mana spirits
that enter with an indestructible
counter and can remove this counter to
do a variety of powerful effects. So in
these instances, we're taking advantage
of the Simic Ceremony's powerful ramp
potential with creatures that don't care
about the rest of this text box. And
already amongst these indestructible
creatures, we can see a lot of points of
cohesion. Erebos plus Myojin of Blooming
Dawn can draw a billion cards, and any
big Erebos plays are assisted by a free
sac outlet like Yahenni. Athreos,
Shroud-Veiled and Myojin of Grim
Betrayal both work fabulously alongside
conventional board wipes, as does
Breathkeeper Seraph to a lesser extent,
and Myojin of Cleansing Fire is a board
wipe. The picture that's being painted
so far is of a big mana controlling
aristocrats oriented deck. And to
minimize friction, we're going to want
to expand on that vision and make sure
it's a consistent feature of the deck,
starting with mana.
The Simic Ceremony provides us a lot of
mana through its discount. So, the first
order of business in making sure the
deck works without it is adding a lot of
other ramp, finding analogs. Heartless
Summoning is the easiest choice here as
a similar two-mana creature discount
plus downside sort of effect. And
another solid choice is ramp on ETB
creatures like Solemn Simulacrum,
Skyscanner, and Coffin Cartographer.
These work on their own as an alternate
ladder from four to six mana to get the
commander and give an immediate coin
destination, and they also function
quite enjoyably with the Simic Ceremony
in play, costing two less mana and
getting their two-two bodies replaced
with two-two zombies. Past these, I
choose to add Crowded Crypt as a
synergistic rock, a Sol Ring, Mer
Convert for subtype purposes, the World
Tree that the deck needs to have 50 or
more subtypes, remember, and seven other
two-mana rocks to round things out. This
deck ended up pretty high curved, so
playing a mana rock is really what we
want to be doing with our two-mana turn.
So, okay. Step one of this was making
sure that this deck can make use of the
Simic Ceremony's mana generation, and
that it has plenty of other ways to
generate mana in the card's absence.
Great. But, let's think a little harder
about this second line of text. It's
intended to be a downside, but does it
have to be?
The biggest area where it isn't a
downside is when it comes to creatures
that we actively want to die. Take
Junji, the Midnight Sky. Both the
discard and the reanimate modes of this
death trigger are solid three-mana
effects. And with the Simic Ceremony,
you get that plus a zombie and a death
trigger and a thing in your graveyard
you can use for other purposes. More on
those things later.
Same with Ao. One mode is a sort of
Collected Company effect, and the other
is a big amplification to our board if
we're already loaded up with zombies.
Both great to get for three mana, and
even better with some extra goodies
tacked on top. We've also got Erebos,
Bleak-Hearted, and Dark Prophecy as
powerful draw engines when creatures
die, which pair nicely with both zombie
tokens and our non-token creatures
meeting an untimely demise.
All of this on death stuff goes great
with the Simic Ceremony, though it does
also pose a bit of a problem. These
cards are a lot less good if we don't
have a way for creatures to die. If we
assume the Sidisi Ceremony will always
be in play, we're going to run into some
problems when it's not. So, this deck
also integrates a number of ways to
sacrifice our creatures as well, analogs
for Sidisi Ceremony's destroy effect.
Season of Loss is a flexible removal
tool that can also draw. Fanatical
Devotion is a sack outlet that can also
save creatures from destruction, and
there are five other cards that do some
sort of sacrificing task. These are
perfect here because they replace the
creature death portion of what the
Sidisi Ceremony does, but most of them
are also great when paired with the
Sidisi Ceremony. And this is the perfect
relationship to create with a
build-around card. You want the best
possible spread of situational
usefulness on a card, not just the one
that's best when paired with a hidden
commander. The same logic applies to
this deck's 19 ETB creatures. Each of
these will have a bit of a spread when
it comes to how effective they are, but
the floor is decently high, making their
footprint relatively low. As a baseline,
they're fine. A deck that's casting a
standalone Simulacrum, a standalone
Chupacabra, a standalone Grotesque
Abomination, at worst you're talking
about bracket two midrange deck
territory. Bring in the Sidisi Ceremony
and suddenly the power of these jumps a
couple notches up from that,
particularly for the three to four mana
ETB creatures. Those creatures are
around 2/2 already, so the Sidisi
Ceremony basically just looks like a two
mana discount that shoves their real
body into the graveyard. Speaking of
which, this is where the Aristocrats
stuff we mentioned earlier comes into
play again. This deck has five cards
that recur creatures, and it also has
the seven sources of creature sacrifice
I mentioned earlier for when the Sidisi
Ceremony isn't in play to assist
creatures with their journey to the
graveyard. And when you're using one of
those and have a bit more flexibility on
your timing for creatures dying, Athreos
also works as a recursion engine,
offering a ton of value generation
alongside of one of the deck's four
sources of continual sacrifice. If
you're getting a Sepulchral Primordial
trigger every turn, a Krob omination
trigger every turn, or a couple Ashen
Rider triggers every turn, you're going
to be feeling pretty fabulous about
things.
There are also a few flicker cards baked
into the deck to enhance the ETB plan
further, as well as an extra spicy
inclusion, Mirror of Life Trapping.
This is an artifact that exiles
creatures when they enter if they were
cast, and then returns them when the
next creature enters after being cast.
In one sense, this is like a convoluted
table-wide ETB doubler, which works with
our ETBs, but it also pairs beautifully
with the Sidisi Ceremony. Instead of
getting destroyed, we can order our
triggers so that the creatures get
sucked into the mirror instead, and then
they can join their zombie friend
whenever the next creature comes into
play.
It's actually crazy to me that this
isn't run in more Sidisi Ceremony decks.
Panharmonicon itself is run in 8% of
decks with the card, and yet the number
of people running Mirror of Life
Trapping doesn't even cross the 2%
threshold to make the EDHREC page. Wild.
This inclusion also brings us back to
the idea of footprint, how good it feels
to be devoting deck space to a given
card. Mirror is a great accompaniment to
the Sidisi Ceremony, but in a deck with
19 ETB creatures, it'll also just feel
solid in general most of the time. This
fact is important because this deck is
designed in a way that the task of
mitigating the Sidisi Ceremony's
downside is nice, but not essential.
Obviously, we won't always have the card
in play, and even if we do, there are a
single-digit number of creatures that
will be really bummed if we play into
it, mainly engines like Braids and Sun
Titan.
These do exist, but because the number
of them is small, it wouldn't be worth
the deck slot to run a card like
Shielded by Faith that would only exist
for the purposes of mitigating
Ceremony's downside. It also wouldn't be
worth it to try and make that mitigating
card feel more useful by running
additional creatures that we don't want
the Sidisi Ceremony to bonk, because
then we'd be sad when we drew the Sidsic
Ceremony but not the Mitigator. However,
what we're doing with Mirror of Life
Trapping here threads the needle
perfectly. The deck is built to mostly
feel good with the Sidsic Ceremony and
to also feel decent with Mirror of Life
Trapping. And the fact that these pair
with each other to give the deck a bunch
more flexibility is a bit of extra sauce
that pushes Mirror over the edge into
being a worthwhile inclusion. Another
example of this idea is Fanatical
Devotion, the enchantment I mentioned
earlier that allows its controller to
sacrifice a creature in order to
regenerate a creature.
This is nice with the Sidsic Ceremony
since zombies generated by it can
effectively pay to prevent it from
destroying future creatures, but it's
also just solid as a protection spell
and it's a sack outlet in a deck that
can do some very juicy things with a
sack outlet. None of these three tasks
would be good enough on their own to
justify giving them deck space and even
doing two of the three might not be
enough, but put all of them together and
you've got a card that slots into the
deck nicely.
So at this point we've constructed a
deck that feels decent without the
Sidsic Ceremony in play and hopefully
pretty great with it. However, I've
omitted arguably one of the most
important parts of a hidden commander
deck, the tutors. There are four of
these and they slot nicely into the deck
since three of them are ETB creatures
and they all have other useful targets
to grab.
And that's kind of all there is to say
about them. It might be a little odd to
you that I saved them for last and spent
all of 27 words telling you about them,
but in truth tutors shouldn't be the
focus of your attention if you're trying
to decide if building around a card in
your 99 is feasible.
You'll probably want them if you want
the card to be part of your plan more
often, but focusing first on how the
deck works without the card is going to
be your easiest road to having a deck
that is fun and flexible.
I also skimmed over tutors because this
is the part of the video where I get to
pull the rug out from under this whole
operation and tell you that both of the
principles I've mentioned in this video
also apply to ordinary commanders that
live in the command zone as well.
Principle [snorts] one was run analogs,
cards that do an equivalent task as your
hidden commander. The reason for that
was that you won't always have access to
your hidden commander, either due to
removal or due to not finding it. So,
it's useful to be able to still have
some access to whatever that card gives
you.
That principle isn't quite as important
with your actual command zone, since
drawing the card isn't part of the
equation, but it still might be
genuinely useful as a piece of advice.
If your commander costs a lot of mana,
having cards that do something similar
to what it does at a lower cost might
help you to have fewer awkward periods
in a game when you can't quite afford to
cast the card. If your commander is a
creature, having a non-creature
permanent that does something similar
could help if you're playing against a
deck that thrives on clearing out boards
of creatures. Having a deck that feels
truly fluid and cohesive generally means
having different options pointed in the
same general gameplay direction, and
this will often mean cards sharing some
of the functions of your commander.
Principle two was to minimize the
footprint of synergizing cards, and this
is the much more broadly applicable one
in my mind. If you're adding cards to
your deck that specifically play well
with your commander, it's good if those
cards are as flexible and multi-purpose
as possible. If I'm playing a Hackball
deck, Silvergill Mentor and Jungleborn
Pioneer will both pair fabulously with
the commander, since they give me two
bodies for one card and can be curved
into Hackball. However, these might not
actually be the best inclusions, because
what if Hackball gets removed and I
don't feel like shelling out command tax
just yet? What if I draw a different
card I'd much rather play on turn four?
What if I draw into some synergy pieces
that push advantage in a slightly
different direction than my commander on
my current board state? What if I'm
expecting a board wipe soon? If I add
cards to my deck specifically to
synergize with my commander and that's
all they do, I'm kind of forced into
playing and replaying my commander again
and again in order to make those cards
useful, even when it might be better to
develop other parts of my game plan.
This is where the minimized footprint
comes into play. Cards that do multiple
things for your deck, feel useful in
multiple situations, these give you more
freedom in how you play the game. The
easiest way to go with this is having
cards that have both a card type you
want and also ramp, draw, or remove
something. But you can get a lot more
intricate with how you make cards feel
useful if you try.
I do think some people go too far and
suggest that your deck should always be
able to function just fine without your
commander. And this does feel a little
silly to say about the commander format.
Still, making sure cards feel good
across a variety of different situations
or are truly powerful enough to
compensate if they're not is a good way
to improve your decks and your
experience with the game.
Thanks for watching and thanks to
Archidekt for supporting the channel.
Archidekt's easy-to-use search bar is
great for building decks like this. I
can type something like enter or
sacrifice or exile and it'll instantly
isolate the cards I want to look at. A
link to this deck is down in the
description. Also, I'm halfway tempted
to actually build and play this deck
since it seems like fun and it's pretty
cheap. So, if you want me to do that,
you can type "This deck looks like a
burning trash heap, Alex." down in the
comments to goad me into it. Anyways,
also supporting the channel is Dragon
Shield, creators of quality sleeves,
deck boxes, and more. I've recently been
using their black outer sleeves for a
somewhat strange purpose that I'll
probably get into at some point. You
might know if you played a game against
me recently. And the fit, durability,
and shuffle feel of them has been good
as always. Follow the affiliate link
down in the description and use code
Salubrious at checkout to get a 10%
discount on your order. If you want to
support me more directly, you can become
a YouTube member or sign up for my
Patreon. I made a short bonus video to
go with this one about the other
restrictions my Sub Six Ceremony deck
had, as well as the nature of strange
deck restrictions in general. A preview
for that begins right now. On the
opposite end of the spectrum, following
specific deck building restrictions
first and foremost can also make decks
more generic, especially if you're
trying to make the deck relatively
powerful. This is obvious in the case of
something like Volo that encourages
players to have an especially wide
variety of different creatures, but it
could even apply to more neutral
restrictions like a Garuda or Obosh
companion. These are some of the hardest
companions to turn into a strong deck
due to how severely they restrict the
card pool.